the theme of mortals been transformed
into animals and other hideous monsters
as a form of punishment is one that we
can see all through Greek mythology and
today we take a look at the story of
Arachne the woman cursed by the gods to
spend eternity as a spider because she
was brave enough to challenge them and
emerge victorious over the years there
have been many versions of Arachne story
and even to this stage she can be found
in modern-day pop culture ranging from
TV shows to marvel comics to a host of
other modern fantasy books but my
favorite rendition of the tale is by the
Roman poet Ovid in Ovitz version Arachne
was the daughter of a shepherd who began
weaving at a very early age but there
are versions where she was a daughter of
Edmund of colophon a man who made a
living from dying cloven the color of
purple hence Arachne skills and interest
in weaving she possessed such a talent
when it came to weaving but her work
became extremely famous and people would
travel thousands of miles just to get a
glimpse at her tapestries as her
reputation grew so did her ego many
would often tell her that her work could
even rival the creation of a god and
eventually Arachne began to believe this
was true we got us Athena took great
offense that Arachne refused to
acknowledge that her skill came from the
goddess as a gift so Athena disguised
herself as an elderly woman and appeared
to Arachne you can never compare
yourself to the gods plead forgiveness
and Athena may spare your soul Arachne
refusing to heed the elderly woman's
advice replied ha I only speak truth and
if Athena thinks otherwise and let her
come down and challenge me herself and
so Athena removed her disguise and
appeared to Arachne in all her glory
except in the challenge the contest
began and both women weaved away
furiously Athena's we even represented a
contest between gods and mortals
ultimately in the new immortals being
punished for comparing themselves quite
an ironic piece of foreshadow right
there
Iraq knees work either differed greatly
showing how gods misled and abused
mortals depicting Zeus is seducing
countless women when Athena saw that
Iraq needs work not only insulted the
gods and her father but also was far
more beautiful in her own work she was
furious riffin Arachne's tapestry into
pieces and beaten the go in the process
Arachne was now disgrace
no one would ever want to buy her work
again and no man would ever marry her so
she chose to hang herself Athena not
wishing for the girl to die said live on
and yet hang condemned one the same
condition is declared as punishment
against your descendants to the last
generation the goddess took some of her
cartas herb and sprinkled it over acne
this herb would act as a poison
instantly cause in Iraq knees hair to
fall out along with her ears and her
nose she grew thick black hair all over
her body and she had eight legs and from
her belly she had a single piece of
thread Athena had shrunk Arachne into
what the ancient Greeks believed to be
the first spider the name rectly is
where many of the english words
referring to spiders came from include
an arachnid and arachnophobia the
details of the transformation do vary
depending on the tale somebody that
Arachne was literally turned into a
spider which would continue to weave but
in the form of a web others believe that
Iraq needs lower body became that of a
spider and her upper body remained that
of a human creating a monster in a
similar vein to Medusa the story of
Arachne is yet another warning of the
fate that awaits those who dare to
challenge the gods in ancient Greece
over than many others believed that the
lesson behind this story was that no
matter how skilled you are you should
always know your place in society now
this meaning may be slightly outdated
but we can still look at the story today
as a warning of what happens when we
allow the influence of others and our
own ego to detect our thoughts and
behavior the story of Arachne is
undoubtedly a tragic tale and if you
have any thoughts or different versions
of the story that you'd like to share
then please do so in the comments below
as always I've been your host mythology
and fiction explained
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]